I was just mad because I was like you
know I'm not even Mexican you know like
but I have my sunglasses on he didn't
see the eyes you know
[Music]
so
um apparently there has been a
prostitution issue in California as of
late has the name you don't say what is
it what's the issue
the news on the street Joe where is this
like Figueroa Street kind of [__] like
that and San Francisco a lot A lot's
been going on but it's so cold over
there what's the issue there's not
enough or it's too little there's a
shortage
yeah I was like wait what they're saying
what people are saying is that the
surgeon prostitution and apparent human
trafficking in California comes after a
change in law took effect last month
that repealed the ban on loitering with
the intent to engage in prostitution so
there's more streetwalkers a band for
loitering that looked like prostitution
so now there's more prostitution okay
all right that doesn't make sense yeah
yeah I hate it when people group
together like prostitution and then sex
trafficking and human traffic yeah
they're very different there are so many
people being like sex workers and
empowering sex work sucks like whatever
and all of them when you like really get
down to it they're like because of sex
trafficking and I'm like they're not
intertwined like that's like saying like
hey I love uh purebred doggies from
reputable certified breeders and then
there's doggy mules you know what I mean
there's puppy mills there's like two
different things
certified and clean and nice the other
one's like in a [__] shady ass like
like a garage they imagine that it's
like taken like the movie they imagine
it's like that it's like duh like no and
a lot of um like
it did and that's how he got arrested
for trafficking it's because of ah take
let's go well no it's not even a hot
take he admitted
on these girls I based
not allowed to go out and all the money
goes to me that is sex trafficking and
he admitted to do it and it's called the
Loverboy method of sex trafficking isn't
that what all pimps do yeah it's what a
lot of hamsters do and a lot of people
Iceberg Slim thought fat skill like on
soft white when those girls talk it's
the story is very similar to that yeah
loves me yeah exactly and a lot of
trafficking people think like you're
getting kidnapped in parking lots which
don't get me wrong I've been uh I've
been like approaching parking lots but
you're also I was like get the [__] away
from me and I called the cops in front
of them
um but like most of it happens from
people you think care about you that
then manipulate you so if you're getting
like no money like even some boyfriends
do that with only fans they're like
let's make an only fans together and
they don't give the girl access to her
own account so that's probably the most
popular method you think yeah it's
modern thousand percent because it's
also harder to catch because then these
women still think well he loves me but
he doesn't it's it's making money off
you yeah so
I I never ran into those kind of girls
that's like um they don't like me do you
know the story of deep throat I never
get a chance you know deep throat
Richard Nixon thing operation deep
throat I don't know if it's that but
deep throat's like it was like a very
famous porn film back in the 70s oh and
it was the first uh porn film that
showed like a girl deep throating and
then that she became were famous off of
that and the movie Deep Throat shows a
story about how it was basically that
her dude was just making her uh have sex
with other guys like and getting paid
the power of love is so strong that's
what tells me women will do anything for
love but also I think I think a lot of
it too is women are taught they're not
enough being by yourself like men are
taught like you are enough without a
woman you're attached to woman if you
just like make money do this do that
even if you don't make money if you have
good deck
you can get girls but girls on the other
hand are taught that you are not enough
and you you need a man to be enough like
you need to get married you need to have
kids like you need to do all these
things and then you can finally be
enough and that's why when women have
all these things they're still unhappy
and have depression and they're like why
don't I feel like enough still it's
because like they need to figure that
out without a man to rely on for
confidence people should just find
themselves that's what I've been doing I
need to go to Hawaii and like eat you
know [__] all of them stop by June
but if you have a waterfall on you you
can find yourself real quick dude you go
snorkeling a little bit I know what
makes me happy now go buy some sage and
[__] and light that [__] up but
I feel like I found myself with acid and
mushrooms I decided to make an only fans
on acid and I was like all of a sudden I
was like tripping at a DubStep show I
was like I'm making it only fans I was
like why didn't I think of this before
oh yeah because I thought my parents
would be embarrassed of me and I didn't
want to embarrass my friends from
college and I was like [__] that I'm
gonna make more money than all of them
and then I made it and that like I
wouldn't have gotten there without acid
honestly what would have happened in
that kind of video we need to send to
all the Asian kids out there to their
parents pursue your dreams there's a lot
of Asian kids [__] trapped in their
own minds for sure so there's a
California politician who has a
suggestion to fix the prostitution issue
in California oh interesting to Legalize
It
okay so I
I most of the dangers of prostitution
sex work even drug dealing comes because
it is it's realized and it's illegal if
you're able to regulate things and make
it safer sex workers like sex workers in
Vegas for example there are like legal
hostels where everyone has to be tested
before going in oh like a bunny ranch
type deal yeah and it's like everyone is
safe it's like you don't have to worry
about someone [__] kidnapping you
because it is regulated and there's like
security and like it is safe for you
like you can't go in with a [__]
knife or a weapon and like with the
drugs too like I have um I get
prescribed ketamine for my anxiety and
it's like you could get ketamine legally
yeah ketamine helps anxiety yeah pick it
up I picked it up at CVS whoa at CVS and
I don't have to worry about it being
lazy so fentanyl I don't have to worry
about [__] dying or oding off of it
and it's like legalization of things and
regulating it is just such I just I it's
it helps so much and it's just all this
hate and spewing nonsense and the war
against drugs and the wars against women
being [__] it's like it just creates a
lot of danger that's true because when I
got a hooker in Amsterdam it felt so it
felt so like chill seamlessly because
there's there's families there just
chilling and just watching like they're
just there for tourism right and there's
guys walking in and then when you walk
up and you just talk to the girls and
whatever like it just feels like you're
at the club it doesn't feel Shady you're
in the alley trying to get your dick
sucked you know
is it my turn yeah you're like it's so
weird
this is I hate that feeling I know it's
the worst dude yeah and then like it's
like brothel and you get a lineup in the
in the and you're thinking in the back
of your mind you're like are these girls
like here on their own will or what yeah
it's like so different but then when
you're at when you're in a space like
that it just it doesn't feel like like
guilty or weird you know what I mean
like it's just I don't know yeah if it's
except then people will accept it if
it's taboo then people will obviously
feel weird about it or do you think
American Amsterdam would go down I think
it would be San Francisco or Hollywood
American well honestly I would already
like sugar daddy stuff is basically like
legalized prostitution where it's like I
don't know I I talked to some people who
as early as like high school like people
are getting scouted girls guys trans
girls like and it's really weird because
in a lot of like in LA specifically it's
like people are being paid
for like sugar daddies or sugar mommies
or whatever and a lot of it is underage
work and I'm like why would you like
that trips me out because that's so
focused on getting a young girl yeah
it's very like obvious why was I-16
being invited to clubs in Hollywood like
that's weird yeah like I was in high
school I I showed the bouncer a credit
card
and they let me in it's good to me oh
Costco plus oh you're right I got
scouted in downtown L.A because I used
to go to the warehouse toy District
because I had an eBay business and it
was a sunny day so I said my sunglasses
like that and then this big dude was
like man I know a lot of men that will
pay for you man they love [__] they're
like they love Latino boys and I was
like I'm not [__] Mexican and I
walked away I was like that's what you
were offended by that part
you're right a lot of men would like me
but I was I was lokila I was kind of
like flattered that I would even be
considered as uh as someone so you ran
back and told them no thanks she really
made me I'm sorry I yelled at you
earlier
I was just mad because I was like you
know I'm not even Mexican you know like
but I have my sunglasses on he didn't
see the eyes you know it was another
there was another time I was at a rave
and then um this girl she broke my ass
she she grabbed it right and then she's
like looked at me like this and then I
wanted to say that's wrong but then my
heart was like thanks I felt really hot
right now
this is what hot people feel like yeah
have you guys ever driven down Figueroa
on off the um 105. probably 105. yeah it
doesn't have an exit but if on right
when Figaro meets the 105 that's kind of
where oh uh like prostitution row is
it's in the suburbs yeah well not
suburbs but like it's there's homes and
apartments around there yeah industry
get up and down and the cops are also
kind of driving around but they have
like an understood thing where it's like
you guys We're not gonna be able to stop
you so at least it goes wrong I knew a
guy that would ride his bike and be on a
megaphone and then like shout like
Christian stuff as he would is he on a
bicycle does he have a megaphone on his
head and he's like that he's your client
dude the guy who used to somebody
University of Arizona like he would be
yelling I forgot what his [__] thing
was but he ended up getting arrested was
it Westborough guys huh Westboro Baptist
Church well I mean I don't know what
church he was in everyone
no but he he hit a girl like physically
oh dude went to jail and got banned from
campus because he wasn't able to get
banned for a while but I remember I do
crazy things like I would be like yo I
just did a bunch of blow last night yo I
just got chlamydia like or like pull my
shorts all the way up and be like how do
you like this ass and he would be so
disgusted with me and I'd love it
I feel like I wouldn't want you to be
attracted to me anyways oh I think those
guys are actually really horny yeah
he was like oh disgusting demons man
yeah I mean Christianity they're like
you need to save your virginity till
marriage but people are getting uh
married when they're like 13 14 15. yeah
they're speeding that [__] it's like how
the [__] are you supposed to be a 40
year old [__] virgin waiting for
someone to fall in love with you and you
don't even know how to [__]
all right I'm a virgin let them know
[Music]